Today's Monday Minute is "Remember why".
When times are tough with your business,
when people aren't believing in you,
when you're not seeing the results that you want in your business,
if you're not seeing ANY results.
Ok? If you're waking up and you feel like you're talking to yourself all the time,
and you're not getting any momentum with your company,
and you feel like you should quit and give up
and you feel like maybe you should go get a job because nobody's believing in you.
If that's happening to you, remember why.
Remember why you started your business, remember why it's important,
remember why this HAS to happen, because every entrepreneur goes through that cycle,
where they feel like they´re going to give up and they go get a job and quit.
And the thing that gets you through is remembering why.
Make sure you have a powerful reason.
Believe!
If you guys liked this video, please give it a thumbs up below.
Leave a comment, leave a question, I'll make a video response.
Thank you so much and I'll see you soon!
Subtitles by the Amara.org community